hey 42 here the name of all the
continents end with the same letter that
they begin with welcome to Mars has blue
sunsets the fine dust in the atmosphere
is just the right size for blue light to
penetrate more efficiently than other
colors in the color spectrum the golden
temple in the western Indian city of
Amarista runs a free kitchen operated by
volunteers that serves over a hundred
thousand hot meals a day it has been
going for over 300 years when the
world's largest diamond the Cullinan
diamond was transported from Africa to
England an elaborate and secure journey
by sea was heavily publicized but it was
just a gigantic distraction the diamond
was simply posted by mail in 1946 a man
claiming to be a detective gave a
pedestrian a camera and asked her to
take a picture of a suspect
the detective turned out to be a
gangster the suspect was actually his
act white and the camera was actually a
concealed shotgun that was fired by the
cameras shutter button in Japan Eber or
crooked teeth in girls is considered
cute and attractive girls actually
undergo procedures to on straighten
their teeth women end up digesting most
of the lipstick they apply in fact the
average woman consumes about free
kilograms of lipstick in her lifetime
the average office desk has 400 times
more bacteria than a toilet the first
time someone attempted to publish two
secrets of the Freemasons in 1826 he was
kidnapped and murdered a study at Oxford
University found that for every person
you fall in love with you lose two close
friends
hamsters only blink with one eye at a
time
in 2002 Steven Spielberg finally
finished college after a 33 year hiatus
he turned in Schindler's List for his
student film requirement an olive tree
can live up to 1500 year
a lump of pure gold the size of a
matchbox can be flattened into a sheet
the size of a tennis court dormitory is
an anagram for dirty room almonds are a
member of the peach family accompanied
by the cherry and the plum thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2
you